okay so now we finish our tour of donald
trump's weekend rallies in nevada donald
trump again
in this rally raised the idea of a third
term
now i want to be really clear the reason
this is notable is no longer because
donald trump really thinks he's going to
get a third term or is going to try to
get a third term he won't
this is notable because it exposes his
followers as merely sheep who care about
nothing other than getting behind trump
no matter what he says
trump says fill the supreme court seat
sure fill it
trump says i deserve a third term sure
third term
trump says we're the best on coronavirus
no matter what the numbers say
sure we're the best on coronavirus there
is nothing they won't cheer for
and here they are cheering for donald
trump's suggestion of a third term
naturally slurring his way through the
speech
and 52 days from now we're going to win
nevada
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
and then after that we'll negotiate
right because we're probably
based on the way we were treated we're
probably entitled to another four after
that
and it should never happen to another
president it's just
a dishonest group of people but here we
are
and we're going to be here so that's the
notable thing that the crowd cheers
even if you like this guy which already
signals a problem
if you believe in the basics of the
united states
don't you have to boo the suggestion of
a third term because a third term is
fundamentally not what this country is
about
we revere george washington for saying
term limits president not a king but
don't worry guys it's just a joke right
well either way
the fact that he keeps repeating it
without a hint of sarcasm is a problem
but what should really scare us is that
the crowd
cheers trump then went on to say that
the biggest
problem the country has right now is the
media
not the coronavirus pandemic not an
unhinged lunatic in the white house
not any of the other problems we
actually have it's the media
it's hurting our country it's hurting
our country
they're the biggest problem that this
country has is the fake news media
worse than the democrats because you
know the democrats and their partners
they played together joe biden
spent the last 47 years selling out
america offshoring your jobs
and then trump continuing to slur just
very labored speech calls joe biden a
pathetic human being
if trump was someone that tried to talk
to you at a bar
you would sidle over to the opposite
side of the bar
to china and you haven't seen the last
of it
sleepy joe biden surrendered you know
where he is now
he's in his damn basement again
no he's in his basement
he's in his basement but you know i can
be bad to him because he put the most
vicious ad on television that i've ever
seen
do you know what i'm talking about where
i'm standing
over the graves of our fallen warriors
our fallen heroes
these are great people the greatest
people there are
and i'm standing over there and they
have some sleaze bag reporter from a
third rate magazine having some source
quoting me
saying i won't even use the term but
saying bad things
and there's nobody that loves our
military respects it
and the people more than me and they
took
and i didn't even ask we had 25 people
that were witnesses that are
on the record already that have said
that never took place
fox news fox news by the way instead of
covering the trump rally when this was
going on
they ran a segment on the impact of
singing
happy birthday on the transmission of
coronavirus with a bunch of panelists i
don't recognize
other than cultural critic and arbiter
of ideas
dave rubin that's how bad this was that
that's what fox news was talking about
trump then uh continues to repeat this i
don't even know where this came from
this idea that joe biden wants to ban
energy just ban it all together and then
we got hit with the plague the china
plague and
we're not uh we're not thrilled it's a
disgrace nobody should have died
nobody should have died we got hit the
whole world got hit
but they stopped it from going into the
rest of china
they stopped it from going into china
but they didn't stop it from coming into
the us
and europe and 188 countries
so whether or not we allow biden to
impose the biggest tax increase in the
history of our country four trillion
dollars
or ban air he wants to ban energy of
been american
he wants to stop fracking hey by the way
completely ridiculous of course
ban energy but stopping fracking sounds
pretty good
i hope joe biden will stop fracking if
he becomes president
and then donald trump apparently not
getting a strong enough reaction to that
scaling up the unhinged claims about joe
biden
saying if biden gets elected there will
be countless deaths from suicide
and tr and biden will permanently
destroy the lives
and dreams of tens of millions of
americans
if he got in we would have the greatest
depression
in the history of our country i mean it
i think 1929 would look like good times
all right
because he'd do everything wrong he'd
raise your taxes he'd raise the hell out
of interest rates he'd do everything
wrong
the biden shutdown will permanently
destroy the lives and dreams of tens of
millions of americans
inflict totally lasting harm on our
children and lead countless deaths
from suicide don't forget when you do
these shutdowns your state is shut down
you got a governor you're shut down
there really aren't words to describe
how absurd all of this is policy
analysis forget about it even
coherent criticisms of his opponent
forget about it
even an accurate presentation of the
facts from which he can make his
unhinged attacks
forget about it and then last clip i
challenge you
make sense of this rant about antifa
i dare you to do it take a listen and
with that comes tremendous crime
and you know i was being i was talking
the other day
darling somebody just moved next door
who is it
it's a representative of antifa
she will look at her husband say darling
we're out of here
we're out of here antifa remember they
were trying to blame
uh other people they don't like to
mention the name antifa
i said it's antifa and i was right i was
right they're bad people
and you know what they have to pay a
price for the damage and for the
horror that they've caused they have to
pay a price
and it's so easy what is he
even talking about the rallies will
continue
this week we will have coverage of some
of them
not healthy to watch too much of this
stuff i will have coverage of some of
them
live on youtube twitch and facebook
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people
quit smoking and vaping by offering a
clean
affordable nicotine alternative now
many of you know you've heard the
stories i've known several people in my
life who have struggled with quitting
smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link
right underneath this video and you'll
get 20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical